you've been introduced the idea of
scientific notation before
but let's just review it because been a
few days right okay
scientific notation can someone give me
an example what does scientific notation
look like
yeah you've got a 10 to the power of
some number like say
i don't know five and then at the front
what do you have
if we wrote it out as a full number
there'd be no i guess
five zeroes right but at the front
you've got some you know significant
figures of some kind
okay so you've got a number like this
that's what scientific notation
looks like can you remember why what's
scientific notation for what's the point
why do scientists use this kind of thing
to make it
like more simple yeah that's right it's
simpler to write
very large numbers or alternatively
very small numbers like zero point
nitrogen you're saying zero zero zero
zero zero
three four um it's easier to write big
and small numbers
in scientific notation it doesn't
require so many zeros okay
so i just want you to remember how do we
actually convert
a number into scientific notation so if
i gave you this
i'm just making this up right now
okay that's a big number right it's a
good candidate
for something we can turn into
scientific notation okay
so i'm going to say equals right now
i've got a few different pieces here
and i want to work out what do i do for
this one that'll make it look like that
right so what was the very first step
how many significant figures does it
have
it has four significant figures one two
three four these zeros
doesn't matter okay so the very first
step is write down the first significant
figure
so there you go five so you can jot that
down
what do you get after the five just this
point you're always going to get a
decimal point
after bless you that first significant
figure
so five points what happens after the
point
yeah just the rest of significant
figures right in this case two
three and eight and you can see just
like um so
i mentioned before there's four
significant figures here and four
significant figures
here okay now look back again
i need to multiply by 10 to the power of
something don't know
10 to the power of something now to work
out the something
i want to look at where this decimal
place has gone and where it came from
okay now i'm not going to change the
number i'm just going to put a point 0
there see that
hasn't changed the number it just puts a
decimal point in
the position that it should be now i
want to work out
how far did this decimal point move in
order to end up over here so i'm going
to count
right here's how i'm going to do it it
goes one place
and i'm just going to keep on going all
the way 2 3
4 5 6 7.
you see that and now it's between the
five and the two
okay so since it moved seven times
or seven places
that way okay i'm gonna say 10
to the power of seven and that's it
you've converted okay
that was a big number let's just for the
sake of illustration i'll give you a
small number
suppose we have this 0.0046
okay
i'll ask the same question how many
significant figures
five okay now there are five digits
right
but are all of them significant now over
here in this example i had a bunch of
zeros
and i said now these zeros not sitting
it could be like an estimate like a
round number
zero is before uh yeah okay we'll get to
zeroes are sometimes significant so
that's good
but i'll show you why in a second these
ones aren't and some other ones are
okay now in this case there are just two
significant figures the four and the six
okay so what did i do up here
i wrote down the first significant
figure right that's a four
okay then what
decimal point and then the six the other
um
significant figure and there you go two
here two there
now i'm going to multiply by ten to the
power of something
right so i'll do exactly the same thing
my decimal point i want it here
but it started over here so i just have
a look at how many times it moves
i count one two
three times and that's where it ends up
okay now here's the thing though
remember we said this is a big number
big number here small number here so
that means
this isn't three even though it moved
three places right do you see why
it moved in the other direction okay so
that's why it's going to be not three
but
negative three okay
now just on um on jax question before
sometimes zeros are significant i'll
show you when they're significant
if i change this number and put a zero
there
see that one there that's different okay
that zero is significant
why why is that one significant but
these ones weren't
um it's because of what's on either side
right
you see you've got a four there and a
six right
so because those are not zero
we know they must be significant and any
numbers between them
regardless of what they are are
therefore also significant yeah that was
no
six so if it was like this
okay now if it were written like that
which i'll admit is unusual i would
actually probably conclude
that it is significant okay but this is
a bit tricky
this is tricky like if i gave you the
number 40
you would guess that there's just one
significant figure right but suppose
there was you know two classes of um you
know year 10 mats and i counted you up
and there was exactly 40 people
not 39 not 41 exactly 40.
in that case both figures would be
significant right
but you can't tell that just by looking
at the number you can only tell because
i explained
extra stuff right in the same way it's a
bit tricky here we would avoid
writing that and giving that to you as a
question unless we provided extra
information
okay yeah what does truncate truncate
means
chop off so just now i had a six there
and i truncated the six so i
i sliced it off okay so that's all it
means